[Music]
hey guys thank you so much for joining
us live on ETS YouTube channel right now
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and I'm so
thrilled because two of my favorite
Roswell New Mexico boys Tyler Blackburn
and Michael Glamis are joining me right
now hi guys did a really great job we
were laughing up until that very last
moment and we collected ourselves like
yeah stop stop laughing I feel like we
did a lot of that on set actually like
we would be like you know we'd have to
really get into character quickly
because I feel like you and I just cuts
it like shooting we had a pretty good
time with it but I will say that you and
Michael Trevino nope anyone seen the
group scene and even I was breaking off
like I was busting up laughing I don't
have tape for no review no we could not
it's the energy makes you laugh got
those great cheekbones your whole cast
has great cheekbones just looks real
nice there's something in the water in
Roswell and for all you fans who are
watching us right now sending your
questions for Michael and for Tyler
because I will be getting them right now
we're starting to get in a bunch right
now oh you guys I gotta say
congratulations on the premiere of
Roswell New Mexico
fans are already loving it so much what
is the reaction been like for you guys
so far you go first
oh man honestly I feel like you don't
realize how supported and loved you are
until something if you do something I
feel like this getting on a show is
extraordinary right I was not going to
show a year ago I'm very grateful for
being here it's amazing but the people
that have just come out and been like
hey I remember one conversation we had
two years ago and seeing you do this has
you know propelled me to continue acting
yeah or you know just keep believing in
myself and so it's just I would say just
like the support from family and friends
is it's almost been overwhelming but at
the same time it's exactly what you'd
want oh I'd rather be bombarded with
texts and love and yeah you know be
alone I you know I feel like I got to
this point the right way
and I think people are aware of that and
I feel that love right now I love
following you on social media so that
you can I
you see all of the the like you know
instagrams that your friends do and it's
like all just like joking but they give
you such a hard time and it's so but no
and I think that's great because like
this whole journey is like so cool to
watch somebody who is such a good person
like you know and we really we got to we
spent the premiere together like the
whole cast so you know that was really
fun too because it was just like this
magic happening in a barn with our kids
like people were crazy I mean like
literally so right there the response
was amazing but yeah like the social
media response they're calling Alex
Malik so you already have your I think I
mean Michael and Alex Malik's I'm Alex
I'm taking that I'm doing that what has
it been like for you guys because we got
to see your characters kiss a little bit
in the pilot we know that there's gonna
be a great love arc for them how did you
guys find that off that on-screen
connection off screen oh it was easy
yeah I mean I feel like during the pilot
which we shot actually last March I
think it was Albuquerque in Albuquerque
we just I feel like it was like an
unspoken agreement we were just gonna
dive right in we were not gonna hold
back in any way no and you know I think
jewel even said like that was her
favorite scene the kissing or kiss
people were crying on set when that
happened on the pilot and that was our
last shooting day too
yeah it was Luther so I kind of really
wrapped it buttoned up the whole
experience you know being out there for
three and a half weeks with this like
new family and then that happening and
you just felt very very proud to be a
part of something like that yeah
yeah but I mean as far as like getting
that energy flowing you know off it was
just like I think honestly to committed
artists like let's just do this
you know and I think that's all it takes
actually yeah we have our first hand
question and right no Natasha wants to
know what do you like best about your
characters oh I like that mine's
unpredictable I love it so much
give us Michael's alien power breakdown
right now what exactly can he do so it's
all it's telekinesis right so which kind
of do anything you can levitate things
with your mind you can blow things up I
can touch somebody and they go flying my
only thing though about my alien the
breakdown of my powers is that I just
cannot control them loose cannon so it's
it's very in the show he can control
them he just actively chooses not to
yeah I think a lot of things in our
lives yeah
Tyler talk to me about Alex my favorite
thing I mean it's hard cuz I feel like I
understand him unlike a pretty deep
level of pretty human level so I think
really it's like the entire his entire
arc of the seasons is I know it's such a
broad answer but it's like that's my
favorite part could you watch somebody
who starts off the season in one place
mentally and physically and you watch
him evolve and and change for the better
so I think to play someone who has such
a realistic arc and and have that
opportunity it was great one of the
things that I'm so excited about is to
see your characters start to interact
with more characters on the show because
you as a cast you guys are so close and
you guys look like you have so much fun
together how did you guys bond together
while you were filming in Santa Fe you
know yeah we were kind of stuck with
each other but it was in it was from the
pilot from Albuquerque to the months off
to go into Santa Fe the cast immediately
it was one of those things when we
called cut at the end of the day and
you're off set we wanted to be together
again
whether it was grabbing dinner drinks
are just hanging out
I don't know we yeah weird way we kind
of couldn't get enough of each other
yeah everybody has like their own method
to like I'm more of a homebody so it was
like you know like just to the Opera in
Santa Fe yeah yeah there's an opera it's
beautiful out half outdoors happened I
mean it's a great yeah it was stunning
an intermission I was a little hungover
and I just was feeling bedtime you know
I'm old now I don't feel like came
thought by it yeah yeah but I love that
The CW has really been leaning in to the
crash day on the crash site they had a
really great premiere event in LA and
you guys all went and bonded together as
a cast what was that like to see the
grand scale of things it was all for
your show yeah and then the alien pods
do really yeah that was cool yeah I mean
it's it's great to feel supported by
everybody that's you know involved in
this show I feel like everybody yeah
just pushing it and it's so cool that
yeah I feel like we're getting a really
good response right and it really was
our first opportunity to all sit and
talk about the show which I was a little
bit nervous about because it really was
like such a labor of love you know and
so like that opportunity to really break
it down was was nerve-wracking but also
really really great you know yeah
Laila ascended in a really cool question
she said Tyler do you have any advice
for the kids who have to live with the
Tyrion achill father like Alex's how
does it affect him in his life Wow
mm-hmm so that's kind of two questions I
I think it affects Alex quite negatively
he feels like he has to change who he is
in order to be loved and accepted by his
father but I think that he's realizing
that he
we'll never be good enough for his
father so I think the lesson in it is to
just do what you need to do to feel
happy about yourself and you know if
people can't be on board with that then
scram yeah you know scram scram that's
right scram
ooh amber wants to know did you guys
watch the original Roswell and if if so
what are your thoughts about it yeah
well I actually I was very familiar with
the show and especially the incident in
1947 yeah I had not seen the show prior
to booking Roswell yeah but I obviously
went back did my research but I really I
I sometimes don't like diving in if
you're gonna you know put your own spin
on something I don't want all these
preconceived notions of how the
character supposed to be or how show
supposed to be I mean we're honoring the
books and Melinda Matz's work but we're
also definitely bringing our own unique
flavor to it and I think sometimes it's
good to just start from Ground Zero yeah
I remember watching the show when it
originally aired that was like 12
because I was like all about the WB like
all of that stuff so I remember I have
like a vague memory of watching that but
yeah I didn't go I didn't try to rewatch
it because similarly I wanted to just
like because we could never do what they
did yeah you know and that's okay
weird yeah we're doing our own you're
doing your own path exactly I think
that's why we're not even calling it a
remake actually we're reading a
reimagining yeah of a concept you know
and making it our own right and also
modernizing it and just really bringing
in a fresh new take Tyler I love that
you said that you used to watch all the
WB shows and let me watch all them and
like see like you're now one of these
like heartthrobs both of you are this
bad boy the bad boys always you know
would you know what I really actually
like about this show is that it doesn't
it doesn't subscribe to like that
formula this show actually has like so
much more
like subtext and substance really and I
think of course you know you know the
cast is really it's good-looking I mean
look at this face Greek Greek god but I
feel like what really makes it special
is that everybody's so talented and can
like really make it so human a lot of
characters yes is there are tons of
secrets in story oh my gosh yes yes
things that you won't see coming at all
which is really fun yeah and just like a
lot of like one-liners that make it very
relevant I mean mmm
the writing I think is so smart you know
so shout out to executive producer
Corinna Adlai Mackenzie was formerly at
television critics have seen all those
tropes that have been done over and over
again so I feel like she's
cherry-picking the good ones and putting
them into yep she understands exactly
what she's doing
you know and if she has an idea for
something there's someone pictures or
something that she'll be like oh that
happened in like season 2 episode 3 of
the OSI we've got just a couple of more
questions
Deidre wants to know Tyler have you
tried recruiting any of your PLL
co-stars to do a cameo on Roswell
no the closest though was the idea of
Troy in directing episode because she
directed an episode of Pretty Little
Liars
and then she directed an episode of
famous in love I think as well so I
thought be really great for her to
direct but then she went and had a baby
then she went had a baby but I'm sure
that we could work something out yes
yeah she's amazing she's an amazing
director have you talked to her since
then since she's very happy
and lastly marina says I'm really
curious about their past and how do they
meet what kind of relationship they had
will we get any flashbacks oh yes about
you guys yeah I get some little tease
about their past oh boy like what can we
I don't know we can say that I will say
that you will all of that will be the
bowl
yeah all of it any question well I think
one thing we can say is that everybody
grew up together basically right so we
have known each other for a while but I
feel like I don't want to say too much
about how the relationship is formulated
I really want you guys to watch it
organically and be part of that yeah I'm
gonna put you guys on the spot right now
what do you think their high school
superlative was back then like I feel
like Michaels was like most likely to
like piss off the teachers okay
you know what's kind of funny I think
both of our characters we were one thing
in high school yeah after high school we
actually change progresses so so that
might have been a little different
because he was like extremely
intelligent yeah going off to college
doing everything potentially and yeah my
character was more um sweeter punk punk
yeah which we see in the pilot and that
image you're looking at yeah before the
big kiss you know yeah kiss a lot of
stubble that hurt a little bit yeah he
said I had to get used to kissing before
you know only only dudes without it holy
dudes about it yeah I mean honestly I'm
kind of in the same boat Oh Mike what
does transpire but you should watch
trailer oh boy here we go trailer so
much I know it's happening tonight I
feel like yeah yeah oh yeah you know
it's I know it's not yes and all you
fans you'll know what's happening when
you tune in to Roswell New Mexico
tonight at 9:00 p.m. on the CW thank you
guys so much for stopping by and
chatting with me thank you fans so much
for watching and we will see you next
time bye bye thanks thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]